السلام عليكم جميعا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اتعرفون من انا
انا احمد احمد الصابوني
شاب في الرابع والعشرين من عمره
انا انسان صريح جدا
واقول للاعور
كما تقول يعني العباره الشهيره اقول
للاعور انت اعور بعينك ولا يهمني ان غضب
اورضي كلمه الحق لا تغضب
ومن قال ان كلمه الحق لا تغضب لا لا تغضب
وتشعر بالقهر ايضا بل وتكون منفره حينما
تكون مغلفه بالكلام الجارح هذه الكلمه
التي ربما نستهين بها في كثير من الاحوال
قد قال فيها رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
حينما ساله احد الصحابه
وانا لمؤاخذون بما نتكلم به يا رسول الله
فرد عليه المصطفى قائلا
ثكلتك امك يا معاذ وهل يكب الناس يوم
القيامه على وجوههم الا حصائد السنتهم
هذه الكلمه التي عندما تراني والدتي
الحبيبه اتكلم بغضب فتقول لي يا احمد اهدى
كلمه تحنن كلمه بجنن
وبدا معها من حولي يتكلمون معي في الامر
فمنهم من يقول يا رجل ما شايف حالك قديش
خالي
يا رجل ما عاد ينشال الاكل من ايدك
ومنهم من يكلم والدي فيقول لهما يا
مشاهدين ابنك عند محلات الاكل ومنهم من
يمزح معي فيقول لي صابون السموني صابوني
وصابوني وكلمات مهينه
فعندما كنت استمع لهم كنت اصغي لهم اصغي
لهم
اضحكوا لمزاحهم ولكن عندما كنت اتركهم
واعود للمنزل كنت افتح باب البراد واكل
اكل اكل بقهر وانا اذكر كلامه المهين زاد
واقول في نفسي ما حدا له علاقه فيني انا
ما عم اعمل شيء غلط حسابي بيني وبين ربي
مضت الايام الى ان وصل الى ان وصل وزني
الى 124 كيلو
دخلت بمرحله مرهقه جسديا ونفسيا بكل زياره
رسميه اقعد البس يا رب دخيلك
شو كل شوي يعني ظهري بده يبين
كلما اردت المشي الى مسافه طويله او اذا
بدي اطلع على الدرج بدي اقعد
فاسد اذا خرجت الى الشارع او الى الجامع
او الى المقهى او الى اي مكان عام اشعر
بان الجميع ينظر الي بنظرات استهزاء حتى
الذي يجلس بعيدا وربما يضحك في غير موضوع
احسب انه يضحك على حال تلك
الى ان جاء ذلك اليوم الذي كلمني فيه احد
الاحباب في الموضوع فقال لي
يا احمد اذا اردت ان تنحف يجب ان يكون
لديك اراده
بدات هذه الكلمه تحدث اثرا في داخلي
الى ان وصلت الى مرحله استجمعت فيها
ارادتي واخذت عهدا على نفسي بالدخول بحميه
قاسيه انقطع فيها عن الطعام بشكل شبه تام
واتبعت المقوله المعروفه
اعتزل ما يؤذيك
فقررت اعتزال جميع علاقاتي اصدقائي اقارب
احبابي ايا يكن بقيت في المنزل لمده شهر
كامل ولم اكن اخرج الا للحالات الطارئه
وكان ما يساعدني على استمرار في حميه رؤيه
وزني الذي اخسر عندما اقف على الميزان
وكلام والدي معي
الله يثبتك يا احمد انت ادى كفي انت عندك
اراده مضى الشهر وخسرت مع مضيه وزنا
مقداره العشرين كيلو عندها قررت كسر عزلتي
ووعدت اصدقائي فعندما شاهدوني
احمد يا رجل شو عامل بحالك فاذا الذي كان
يستهزئ بحالي بالامس اصبح يقول لي يا رجل
بحياه ربك قلنا شلون نحفت كفه لا توقف
وصلت لوزن منيح كفر ووصل للوزن اللي بدك
اياه بالفعل قررتوا الاستمرار على حنيتي
واستمرت حينتي لمده سبعه اشهر خسرت خلالها
ما يقارب الستين كيلو مضت الايام واصبح
احمد
المعروف لدى البعض اليوم اسم صانع المحتوى
فلوجر ايا يكن عندها بدات بالتعرف على ما
كان يؤثر فيا وفي الكثير من الناس الا وهي
الكلمه الكلمه التي عندما كانت جارحه
ومهينه زادت علي ظلمتي وعندما اصبحت كلمه
طيبه ارشدتني الى الصواب وهذا ما يحدث مع
الكثير من الناس اليوم الذين تراهم يصرون
على افعالهم تراهم لا يتقبلون نصحا
منعزلين منطويين ويقولون كما كنت اقول يا
اخي ما حدا له علاقه فينا حسابه بينه وبين
ربك وهم في الحقيقه نعم تعرضوا لكلمه
جارحه ولكن كانت تعرضوا لكلمه لكلمه حق
ولكنها كانت مغلفه بكلمه جارحه وهذا ما
نراه في ابسط الامثله في حياتنا فحتى
الاهل مع اطفالهم في المنزل يعني الطفل
يحب يستكشف
فربما يعني كمثال طفل عم يلعب بالمحارم عم
يشلفن
الاب اجا لعنده
شو انت اهبل شيخ وتراه يوبخه توبيخا شديدا
فترى الطفل يرتعب ويرتعد حينها ولكن بعد
ساعات قليله يعاود الطفل نفس الفعل ولكن
مع حركه استفزازيه وهي النظر الى رده فعل
والده
لماذا فعل الطفل ذلك
ام لماذا عاود او اصر هؤلاء الناس على
فعلهم ام لماذا عدت الى المنزل واكلت بقهر
لانه لا احد يحب اسلوب التهديد لا احد يحب
اسلوب الاهانه عزه نفسه لا تسمح له
ولو كان الاب قد جاء لولده
وقال له يا ولدي هذه لا تستخدم للاعب حتى
ان كان الطفل لا يفهم الطفل الطفل بيلقط
من اهله حتى وان ما حكوا وعلمه ان هذه
المحارم تستخدم لاغراض التنظيف لفهم الطفل
ان لهذا الشيء الذي يلعب به ويعبث به قيمه
اختياركم
لكلماتكم هو ما سيحدد ان كان هذا الشخص
سيقبل رسالتكم او يرفضها تماما
كلمه طيبه يقول احدهم يا رجل الكلمه
الطيبه هاي نوع من انواع المجامله والنفاق
واذا اردت ان تعرف شخصا عظيم فعله يجب ان
تتكلم معه بحده وقساوه وهذا الكلام غير
صحيح فعندما دخل رجل الى ملك من الملوك
وقال له يا ظالم يا فاجر فرد عليه الملك
وقال اصمت يا هذا اصمت فقد جاء من هو افضل
منك الى من هو اسوا مني فقد بعث الله موسى
وهارون الى فرعون ما مع ذلك قال الله لهما
فقولا له قولا لينا هذا الذي قال انا ربكم
الاعلى فقول له قولا لينا لعله يتذكر او
يخشى
كل قسوه تحتاج الى لين فحتى الحجره الصماء
تقسمها مع الزمن قطره مطر تهطل عليها وكل
قلب قاسي
يحتاج الى كلمه لينه تكسر قساوته تلك ولا
تحسب ابدا انك اذا تكلمت مع هذا الشخص
بكلمه طيبه ولينه انه سيستجيب لك من فوره
ويغير حاله لا لا ابدا بعض الكلمات
كالبذره التي تزرعها في الارض تحتاج لزمن
كيظهر اثرها بين الناس او في قلب من تحدثت
معه فعندما كان هذا الطفل عائدا من مدرسته
وكان هذا الطفل يعاني من ضعف في النطق
وضعف في السماء وكان يحمل رساله من معلمه
مفادها بالحرف
ابنكم يعاني من التخلف العقلي لا ترسلوه
الى المدرسه مجددا فعندما دخل الى ابويه
اعطى رساله لوالدته
فعندما فتحت رساله
قراتها بشكل مغاير تماما فقالت
ابنك عبقري
ولكن هذه المدرسه متواضعه جدا بالنسبه له
وليس لدينا معلمون جيدون لتعليمهم
من فضلك
علميه في المنزل
مضى الزمن واصبح هذا الطفل اول من اخترع
لنا المصباح في العالم
توماس الفا اديسون بعض الكلمات التي نتوقع
ان لا تحدث تاثيرا تفعل اشياء لم نكن
نتوقعها منذ ايام دخل تاجر ميسور الحال
الى المشفى الحاله اكتشاف في العضله
القلبيه السبب
مجلس كان يستمع فيه لما يقول يا اخي البلد
ما عاد فيها الوضع ما عاد
تجارتنا عم تهوى كل مال الليره عم تهوى
الوضع ما عاد محتمل ورجل اخر فقير احواله
متعسره ولكن دخل الى منزله بكامل صحته
وعافيته بعد مجلس استمع فيه لمن يقول
هذا الحال ما بدون
الفرج
انما يوفى الصابرون اجرهم بغير حساب ان مع
العسر يسرا
كلمه واحده يا سادتي يمكن ان تنقذ حياه
يمكن ان تعيد احياء امه
اليس هذا ما نريده جميعا الم ناتي الى هذه
القاعه اليوم كان نستمع الى كي نستمع الى
كلمات تلهمنا
هل يمكن ان اسال سؤالا اخيرا
عندما تقف امام من تحبها او امام من
تحبينه
وتستمعوا لها وهي تقول او تستمعين له وهو
يقول
انا بحبك
بماذا تشعر
اشعر بان قلبك ينطفئ روحك ترقص تتلاثم لا
تستطيع ان ترد فاذا كانت كلمه اصابتك
بشعور لا تستطيع ان تصفه فما بالك باثر
الكلمه التي تقولها في قلوب الناس
سيداتي سادتي كل كلمه نقولها وسنقولها
سيعود اثرها علينا
فكما ندين ندان
وكما نعين نعان والله تعالى قال هل جزاء
الاحسان الا الاحسان وكما تقوله والدتي
الحنونه
اقول كلمه بتحنن وكلمه بتجنن السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله